>>Alex Komoroske: Hi and welcome to HTML5,
What's Next? My name is Alex Komoroske. I'm
a product manager on Chrome focusing on the
open Web platform. And I'm also a Web developer
myself, spent many years working on the Web
platform. That's why I'm so excited about
making it even better.
>>Ian Fette: Hi, everyone. My name's Ian Fette.
I'm a product manager on Google Chrome. I
joined the team about four years ago working
on security and infrastructure, like networking
stack and disk cache. And for the past few
years, I have been focused on HTML5.
>>Alex Russell: Hi, I'm Alex Russell. I'm
a software engineer on the Chrome project,
working on Chrome Frame and the Chrome Web
platform more generally.
>>Alex Komoroske: Cool.
So before we get started, here is the speaker
meter link for this talk as well as the hash-tag
if you feel the need to tweet.
Today, if you came to any of the earlier talks,
you saw a the lot of really cool demos about
what you can do with HTML5 today.
Today we are also going to continue that by
telling you about capabilities that are being
built into the platform today including FileSystem
and WebSocket 3D.
We are also going to spend a lot of time talking
about the future of the Web platform, really
how you can unlock the potential -- what we
think is important for unlocking the potential
of the Web platform going forward.
Some of the things we will talk about are
so new, they are still under discussion there
is no spec for them necessarily yet. And they
definitely aren't implemented.
We think it is important that these kinds
of things are going to be important for making
the Web platform even better going forward.
We will talk about some proposals for CSS,
for JavaScript and also something we call
model-driven views.
But, first, let's very quickly just review
how we got here on the Web platform.
The Web platform started out obviously as
a very -- as a long time ago as a way to share
very simple documents written in HTML. Of
course, that wasn't enough. People wanted
to be able to style their stuff. Now you have
CSS.
Of course, people wanted to be able to add
simple behaviors and so you have JavaScript.
People pushed that basic capability so far,
they built things like Google Maps and Gmail
and Google Docs. You have apps -- real apps
being built on a platform that originally
was designed for documents.
Now, of course, the Web platform hasn't stayed
still. It has been adding tons of capabilities.
You can do some really amazing stuff with
it now with complex graphical effects, video,
even 3D. We are adding more and more capabilities
to the platform all the time, really expanding
the vocabulary of what you can say on this
platform.
Remember, this platform did originally begin
with static documents. And although it is
a very full-fledged, full-featured platform,
some of these features were added ad hoc.
And it takes a lot of -- a lot to wield the
power inherent in the platform today.
So although today you can build incredibly,
amazingly beautifully, powerful apps, it requires
a lot of JavaScript and it requires you to
basically be what I would describe as kind
of a Web development ninja. And not everyone
has the patience to become a Web development
ninja.
That's why we think it is important not just
to expand the vocabulary of the platform but
also to focus on making it so you don't have
to be a ninja to write delightful apps.
We think by doing that, it will really unlock
the potential of the platform.
We think the way to do that is to allow developers
to say what they mean.
Before we get to what I mean by "say what
you mean," let's go to Ian to hear more about
the capabilities in the platform today.
>>Ian Fette: Thanks, Alex. So a quick question.
How many of you were here for Google I/O 2010?
Awesome. I see a lot of hands. And it is really
cool to see so many people here because last
year when Chrome was giving some talks, we
were in what was then the largest room that
held about 500 people. This room here holds
about 750 people and it looks quite full.
So I'm very excited to see all these people
sort of interested in knowing what's going
on.
So Alex sort of gave a great lead-in. We do
think it is important to let you do more on
the Web, to expand your vocabulary, to let
you be more expressive in the types of applications
that you want to develop. We talked a little
bit last year about what we're doing, and
I want to give an update of what's going on
in terms of new capabilities that we're adding
to the Web platform through Chrome.
So if you were at Eric and Arne's talk this
morning, you saw FileSystem being demoed.
FileSystem is something we first talked about
it at Google I/O 2010, so almost a year ago.
There have been a lot of changes since then,
since Chrome 8 when we introduced this.
For those who aren't familiar with FileSystem,
I have a snippet of code which sort of shows
what you can do with a FileSystem. Here I
am requesting a FileSystem that's temporary.
I will talk a little bit more about that later.
I'm creating a file, a simple logfile. I am
going to move to the end of the file. I will
get a writer for the file so I can write to
it. I will seek that to the end. I will write
some data to it. So FileSystem is an API that
let's you store data on the user's computer,
relatively straightforward.
I want to talk a little bit about some of
the changes that have happened since Chrome
8 to actually let you use FileSystem and let
you use it in a more useful way.
So perhaps the most boring change since Chrome
8 is we used to have a lot of references with
respect to URIs. These are now URLs. It is
very simple and straightforward and boring,
but I wanted to get it out of the way so we
can talk about more interesting changes.
What's actually interesting in FileSystem
land, when we first introduced this API about
a year ago, it was only usable within the
context of Chrome apps and Chrome extensions.
If you are developing a Chrome app or Chrome
extension, you can use this now. You can request
unlimited storage quota and you can save things
on the user's hard drive in a structured way,
in a FileSystem. And that's great.
But we've gotten feedback that there is a
lot of people that don't necessarily want
to have to get users to install a Chrome application
or a Chrome extension just so they can use
this API.
So we're working to make this available outside
of apps and extensions, and we're hoping to
have this working on dev channel by the end
of the month. In Chrome 13, we are going to
enable this -- this API outside of apps and
extensions. So that's one big change.
But the second big change, for those of you
that have tried to use a lot of the storage
APIs, be it FileSystem, WebSQL Database Indexed
Database API, AppCache, you often hit this
five-megabyte limit. You are like, Wow, what
can I actually do with five megabytes?
If you are trying to store a user's email,
my inbox is somewhere around 30 gigabytes.
You are going to hit that five-meg limit pretty
quick. If you are trying to let users edit
photos and then upload those, again, five
megabytes, it is like poof, gone.
It is like, Can you just get rid of that five
megabytes? No, we can't because if we get
rid of it entirely and say, Sure, we will
store data on the user's computer and we'll
never delete it, it will be there for you,
then anyone can sort of just fill up the hard
drive. This isn't a good solution.
So what we're trying to do is we're trying
to introduce a notion of quota. The way we
are doing this, there's two things happening.
One is that we now have a notion of two types
of quota: One is temporary, one is persistent.
The way you interact with this quota is through
an interface called StorageInfo.
So before I get into StorageInfo, let me explain
what temporary and persistent quota are. First
of all, a lot of APIs nowadays are requesting
-- they're requesting some capability and
then the browser puts up this modal dialogue
or this info bar and says, Hey, user, can
I do X, Y, Z? We really want to avoid this
as much as possible.
What we are doing by creating temporary quota
is we are saying, you, the developer, can
store things on the user's computer. You can
already store things like cookies, so the
actual impact of storing something on the
computer is not that great. And we won't ask
the user. We won't put up any annoying dialogues.
We will just let you have some storage. You
can say, Hey, I want to make the user's email
available for offline browsing. Give me five
gigabytes of temporary quota. We'll say, Sure.
There is, like, 500 gigabytes free on the
hard drive. Here's your five gigs. Have fun
with it.
You can keep doing this and getting more quota.
But, eventually, we're going to run out of
space. And the key thing about temporary quota
is it is managed by the browser. So if another
site requests quota and there's none available,
we have to figure out as a browser how do
we make this available? So we, the browser,
will feel free to delete things in temporary
storage to make room for applications that
users use most frequently.
This let's all the management happen outside
the user's view. There is no annoying dialogues
or prompts, and it just works.
But that doesn't work for everything. What
if you're an offline email program and the
user is typing up an email? You don't really
want that email they've composed to get deleted
by something else. So temporary storage doesn't
work for everything. For this, we have the
notion of persistent storage.
So if you request persistent storage, we guarantee
you that we won't just evict it. We won't
delete it. Because of this, we will ask the
user for permission. So we're hoping that
together this will enable offline apps to
actually make use of the storage APIs.
The interface for this is quite simple. You
can query how much quota you're using and
should you need to request quota, there is
a simple API to request quota.
So this is what's going on in the land of
storage. What else is going on?
Well, last year we talked a little bit about
WebSockets. WebSockets, as you can see on
the screen, is an API for bidirectional communication.
So a lot of applications do this today, things
like chat. You are sending chat messages,
updates back and forth to a server. If it
is email, you might be pulling for email.
And although it is possible to do this, it
is very inefficient right now. You often have
to open two connections. You're sending a
full HTTP request with headers, cookies each
time. Even if you are sending one word, five
bytes, that might get blown up to hundreds
of kilobytes depending on all the headers
and cookies and who knows what else.
So WebSockets is meant to be a very simple
API that lets you send and receive messages
over a persistent connection.
The spec is now in last call as of April so
this is really getting finalized. We've got
a lot of browser interest, all the browsers
are looking at this. Microsoft has an experimental
implementation out that you can download.
FireFox and Opera are both also working on
it. So a lot of momentum around WebSockets,
and now we are sort of changing our focus
to multiplexing so you have even more connections
open at one time and still be efficient.
And last, but not least, 3D. Those of you
who were at the keynote this morning, you
got to see Angry Birds in 3D. This is my absolute
favorite. I'm sort of addicted to it. There
has been a lot of progress in 3D.
As of Chrome 9 back in February, we now have
WebGL enabled by default, not just on the
latest, greatest, Windows 7 computers but
also for people who are running Vista and
XP as well. So WebGL, broadly enabled, that's
really cool if you are building games or things
with immersive 3D environments.
But what if you want to just sort of add some
3D flare? You've got, like -- if you look
at the new tab page in Safari, it has got
these cool 3D perspectives. A lot of things
make great use of 3D not for like a fully
immersive gaming environment but just to add
some nice flare, some nice perspective.
3D CSS transforms are a very way to add this
into your application. I'm very excited to
say that as of Chrome 12 we now have initial
support for a lot of the 3D CSS transforms.
And as Sundar said this morning, Chrome 12
is now going out to the beta channel. This
is something you can already use and will
be out to all users very shortly.
So we're doing a lot to sort of expand your
vocabulary, let you say more things, as you
will. But sometimes this can be a bit overwhelming.
And so to talk about what we're doing in that
aspect, I would like to welcome Alex Komoroske
back.
>>Alex Komoroske: Thanks, Ian. That was an
overview of some of the stuff that you can
do today in the Web platform. But now let's
take it and look towards the future. So once
we've gotten to all of everyone having all
the pieces of HTML5, what's next, right?
The problem right now is that you have this
huge vocabulary. But it isn't necessarily
easy or short or succinct to say the things
you want to get across. This isn't just a
theoretical problem. This is a problem you
running into every single day. Even for simple
sites, popular sites, well-implemented sites,
you are doing a lot of things. You are saying
a lot of stuff just to get some basics across.
The way I think of it is that the Web platform
today is kind of like a savant. He amazingly
smart and he's amazingly effective at doing
precisely what you tell him to do. But he
doesn't understand that much about the real
world.
You have to spend a whole lot of time explaining
to him precisely how the world works, and
you do all this via JavaScript before you
tell him to do anything that's particularly
useful.
And, you know, you can do this. It's possible
to have these conversations. But why should
you have to? Why can't you just have a normal
conversation? And we think that should be
the future of the web platform. Moving from
this idea of saying what you must, this very
comprehensive encyclopedia of information,
and moving just to saying what you mean. Why
should you have to write an entire encyclopedia
and ship it down the wire when all you really
wanted to say is a short story? This is something
that we think is really important, and that
will unlock a lot of the potential of the
web platform. We think there's lots of benefits
from this or good reasons to do this. The
first is reducing maintenance burden. The
more code you have to write, the more service
area you have for bugs and typos. But there's
something else too. If you codify in your
encyclopedia of knowledge about the world
that a car is something with an internal combustion
engine and that uses fossil fuels, well, it's
going to continue being that way even if electric
cars become the norm.
Whereas if you can rely on the platform more
to understand these things natively, these
common patterns, then as electric cars become
normal, you sort of get that for free. You
just say, "Hey, give me a car," not "Give
me something with an internal combustion engine."
Another way to think about it is that reduce
time down the wire. So one of the great things
about the web platform is that you have this
enormous reach. Anyone with an Internet connection
on any number of devices can get your app.
But they also have to be shipped down the
wire. So if you're shipping down an entire
encyclopedia, that's going to take time. But
if you can be succinct, if you can just ship
down your short story, you can get to your
users much faster.
Another way, of course, is execution time.
If you've got this whole encyclopedia that
the browser has to read and understand, that's
going to take some time. Even with really
fast JavaScript engines like V8 and on other
browsers. This is something that will always
take time. It will never be quite as fast
as native code.
There are two ways to fix this particular
problem. One of them is by increasing the
reading speed, increasing how quickly these
engines can process this stuff.
That's incredibly important, and of course
everyone's working on it.
But there's a second strategy, a supplemental
strategy, and that's reducing the amount of
stuff you have to say that the browser has
to understand.
You're raising up the common patterns and
allowing you to express that natively, so
that more logic can run natively and it can
run fast.
That means that you don't have to process
this entire encyclopedia before you can get
to the juicy stuff, the good stuff, the stuff
that you actually care about.
But the final way, and I think the most important
way, is reducing cognitive overhead and complexity.
You as a developer only have a certain amount
of patience and time, and right now you're
spending a lot of that building up this encyclopedia
when really all you want to say is this short
story. Even if you're building on top of exiting
encyclopedias and existing frameworks, there's
still some overhead there. Each of these frameworks
has to build up their own version of the world
and explain it to the browser in an incompatible
way, so, you know, if you've got -- if you're
driving a BMW, parts from a Toyota probably
aren't going to fit. You can't pick and choose
pieces from across these frameworks.
So again, we think that the web platform of
today is amazingly powerful. It's getting
more and more powerful every day. But now
we think it's important to really focus on
allowing people to say what they mean, to
really bring in -- usher in a new era of amazing
Web apps.
And so now that's sort of the high level,
but now let's turn to Alex Russell for some
specifics.
And again, just to set the context here, these
are ideas that are so new, so cutting-edge,
that they aren't in specs yet, let alone being
implemented.
>>Alex Russell: Thanks, Alex.
So as Alex laid out the cogent case for why
we need improvement in not just the vocabulary,
but sort of the slang, the common use cases
of the languages that we use every day, it's
important to ask the question: What is it
exactly that we need to change?
So if we go and we sort of ask anybody and
say, "What is it that you would like to be
different about the web platform," we'd get
a lot of different answers, and in fact, we
have.
And so what we've done instead is go and look
at the largest applications that we're building
because they sort of have aspirational levels
to the complexity. When you throw hundreds
of engineers at a problem, you can expect
them to build something that a couple of guys
in a garage won't be able to do over a weekend.
And so what we'd like to do is make it possible
for you to build richer, more complicated,
more sophisticated applications, without having
to work as hard. And so if we look at the
biggest applications that we've got today,
we've started as to ask ourselves: What are
the areas where we could get the biggest bang
for the buck if we take the common things
that everyone is trying to do and just put
them directly in the platform?
So one of the big things that has been clamored
for by developers since the early days of
CSS has been the ability to refactor your
CSS in a lot of different ways.
The first of them is variables, where variables
names in programming languages are actually
descriptive. They're not just chaff. They're
not just sort of like a stand-in for your
own understanding. They wind up being the
language that you use to communicate to yourself
later and another programmer about what it
is that this value does.
And so what we've looked at is how we're using
CSS in the real world. CSS style sheets have
gotten very large and factoring your CSS has
turned into an incredibly important task for
many large websites. And so CSS variables
unlock a lot of the potential to do exactly
that. And so we're working on a syntax that's
been proposed on the CSS working group mailing
list to help us do exactly that. We're using
a new at rule. As you can see, in this case,
we're going to create a base version of this
value, which otherwise has to be repeated
over and over again in the example at the
top.
Instead of repeating the values, we can start
to repeat what it is we're trying to say inside
of our CSS. CSS variables help us factor stuff
out. And this is going to be great for themes.
This is going to be great for building stylable
websites in which you can put the burden of
maintenance not just on one person who has
to know the entire system all at once, but
you can hand over your variables sort of as
the contract for how you want to theme and
style your CSS rules.
So this is really good. CSS variables give
us the ability not just to do this statically,
but we also want these to be dynamic, so that
you can come back later with JavaScript and
change the value and have them change live
in a document. CSS variables can be an incredibly
powerful way to do that, add dynamic behavior,
not just sort of macro style one-time fire-and-forget
behavior.
So the next thing that we looked at, when
we were looking at very large style sheets,
the sorts of things that get generated from
large teams or from the preprocessors that
are so popular now inside of client and server
side toolkits, is the idea of factoring out
common sub-expressions inside your CSS rules.
So if you look at CSS rules today, we've got
media queries which give us the ability to
say, "Please turn on or turn off this set
of CSS rules for some environment," but after
that, there's no sort of layer that allows
you to target some chunk of CSS to some portion
of your document.
Because what happens in small documents is
that you write very terse, very expressive
selectors and rule bodies which only have
to operate on a small chunk of DOM. But when
we build really big applications, we build
those big applications out of similarly small
chunks of DOM. But if I write a very small
rule that has a descendant selector or is
relatively naive about what it's going to
target, I wind up in a place where I have
to defensively prefix all of my CSS rules
with some ID or some class name, so that I'm
not overbroadly applying my CSS rules to some
portion of DOM that I didn't mean to. We're
trying to get to a place where we can think
about CSS and HTML having this component.
So today we wind up with these shrink-wrapped
rules with a lot of prefixes to get there.
And so one of the things that we think is
going to be helpful in this case is the ability
to factor out common sub-expressions so that
you can mix things in like a function would.
You can say "I don't want to have to write
out the code that does this thing every time.
I just want to import it into my CSS rules."
And CSS mixins give us a way that's analogous
to using variables, but instead not importing
the value of something but importing a bunch
of different rules into a particular CSS rule
body.
So in this case, we've got a themed button
and the themed button doesn't want to have
to care about which style of linear gradient
syntax is supported in which browsers. Instead,
it wants to use whichever one is going to
be available. CSS has been evolving in a very
compatible way, thanks to this vendor prefixing,
but it leads to kind of a diarrhea of vendor
prefix names when you mostly have the same
thing supported everywhere but nobody wants
to implement the exact same unprefixed thing,
lest the spec change out from underneath them.
And there's some transition period after browsers
support the new thing because not all browsers
update automatically.
So we need a way to stop saying the same thing
over and over and over again when we just
want to say it once, and mixins, defined with
this new at trait rule, give us the ability
to do exactly that.
We can pass in variables to mixins so that
they can be paramaterized and then the local
name for that could be populated into the
rule.
You could think of this as sort of simply
expanding in line, inside of our themed button
class, exactly what we were going to say longhand,
but we can reuse that over and over and over
again in different CSS rules. It's sort of
like a macro. So that's pretty good. It's
a macro that we can configure in a bunch of
different places to refactor and factor out
common sub-expressions and common behavior.
So I mentioned earlier that we wind up doing
this shrink-wrapping thing where I have a
little chunk of DOM and I want to factor out
some common rules that apply only to that
thing.
Mixins give us the power of saying "Aha, when
I want to reuse some set of rules that apply
in a bunch of different rules, I can just
turn them into a function or a mixin that
I can use in different places."
But at the same time, we want to make that
stuff appropriate only for the DOM that we
care about.
So this is an example of some CSS from an
earlier version of this slide deck.
So this CSS, as you can see, has dot slide
dot image as this premix that gets used for
a whole bunch of rules that come after the
initial formatting for this chunk of HTML,
and these rules roughly correspond to the
structure of the HTML that these rules should
apply to.
So in this case, the -- any element underneath
this slide image that's got a credit should
have this behavior, whereas any counter-element
should have a separate set of styling applied
to it. And so in this way, we wind up, you
know, using descendant selectors with a prefix
to sort of replicate the structure of our
document in our CSS, so that we don't over-apply
rules and that we don't under-apply rules.
So that we wind up with exactly what we meant
to say in our document without creating a
problem for somebody else. Specificity helps
us here.
But it's very verbose.
So what we're proposing is the idea of CSS
nesting and hierarchy, where you can write
rules in a hierarchical way. Using the new
ampersand character, we are effectively doing
exactly the same thing: shortening up the
subrules by saying when I want to target an
element underneath the slide image with the
credit class applied to it, simply repeat
the selector that was -- simply repeat the
selector that was written out at the beginning
in front of this rule here.
It's sort of like you're not doing the loop
unrolling for the system anymore.
Dave Herman at JSConf last week said last
week that he doesn't think that humans are
very good compilers and that nobody should
be a compiler; compilers are compilers. And
I agree with that statement. We want you to
be able to write only the stuff that you need
to say in order to get your job done.
And so being able to nest your rules makes
it read like you would actually see the HTML
that you're trying to target here, and using
the ampersand to stop repeating yourself so
much makes it possible to read the CSS rules
without quite so much visual cruft, and without
sending so much down the wire in order to
say exactly what it is you were trying to
get to. That's pretty cool.
It's worth noting that all these things compose
together too. CSS nesting and hierarchy works
inside mixins, so I can have a mixin that
has hierarchy inside of it.
Variables work with all of these things.
So we're starting to get to a place where
CSS is a really expressive language that helps
us map behavior and visual formatting back
onto HTML in the way that we want to write
our HTML in the first place: structurally,
semantically, and in a way that is very clear
to read.
So that's great. That gives us some really
powerful tools for maintaining our CSS, structuring
it in ways that are reusable and maintainable
and that don't have high complexity, reducing
the size of our CSS down the wire so that
we don't have to fight so much for performance,
but we have a couple of other parts of the
platform that could use some love here too.
We've gotten out of the world of JavaScript
animations recently, especially in mobile
platforms, by using CSS animations and transforms.
And CSS animations and transforms are a great
way for us to put the job of making things
fly around the screen onto the browser. We
don't have to do it in JavaScript. We don't
have to strip down a library in JavaScript
that's going to do the work for us. We don't
have to come up with a whole set of prebuilt
easing functions. That can all be put into
the browser. It's really powerful stuff and
it's sort of de rigueur on mobile platforms
today.
But we wind up with a couple of problems as
we start to exercise the edge of this syntax.
It's great stuff and we really want it to
be as easy to use as possible.
But today, it's a little bit unclear, when
I look at an animation or a transition, what
it is it's supposed to do.
I think the easiest way to sort of communicate
what it is animations and transitions do is
to think of transitions as being edge triggered.
When I want to migrate from State A to State
B, the transition helps me communicate visually
about that transition, that change in state,
from Point A to Point B, whereas animations
are things that happen at the level in my
step function.
They happen when I reach that state. When
I get to that state, then kick off the animation.
And so transitions are designed to help you
interpolate from Point A to Point B, whereas
animations aren't designed to help you interpolate;
they're designed to help you express some
visual behavior in a way that's very compact
in terms of expression for a fixed set of
things but it doesn't give you a way to reach
in and say where did I start from and where
did I go to.
So it's not clear which one you should use
for each task. If I'm communicating visually
about what just happened to my application,
I might want to use a transition, but there's
some missing expressive power.
If I use an animation, I have complete control.
I can declare an entire set of joined behaviors
and visual artifacts that I'd like to have
spring from me arriving at a place, but I
can't tie that to the beginning and end states
of my application's behavior.
And most of all, when I write my CSS, I sort
of think of writing my CSS as a series of
states.
My CSS rules -- in this case the hover class
-- are a great example of wanting my CSS rules
to express positions that my elements might
be in.
Roles or states that they might take on.
And so if we want to reuse that language on
the selector side of my CSS, we need a way
to tie our transitions and our animations
more tightly to that graph of potential states.
So we're proposing a new set of syntax to
help you do exactly that.
In this case, we're going to reuse the CSS
for the button and the active class as a way
of tying this state, dash, interaction role
to it, which is a way of saying my button
is going to participate in sort of a new set
of classes and in this case that's going to
be the interaction.
And whenever I am in the active state, that
interaction is going to go from normal to
pressed. So when that happens, now we want
a way of targeting that with some new expressive
behavior for visual formatting. We don't want
to have to put that in our JavaScript. We
don't want to have that happen from events
that happen in programmatic code. Instead,
we just want this to happen because the CSS
transition does from one place to another.
So what we've got here is a new at transition
rule. And the new at transition rule says,
when I target the button class and I move
from normal to pressed over the interaction
state, then run this animation over this frequency.
And when -- if I wind up interrupting this,
if I wind up coming back and not applying
the active class for a 10th of a second, reverse
the animation. Automatically reverse it. Today
this is a lot of code to go. This is really
powerful stuff. We can write our CSS as though
it is a series of statements to transition
to and through. We can tie our behavior, our
visual behavior directly to those transitions.
So this is a little bit of code, so the smallest
code I could write, to go and figure out a
way to take the start and the end of a CSS
animation and configure them for something.
I don't expect to you read this or understand
it. But, basically, I pull in a library. I
write a function, which is going to go substitute
some values in and out. Because today CSS
animations can't be subject to some relative
start and end state. So what we need to do
is go calculate that start and end state,
add it to the key frames, add it to a new
rule, apply that rule and those key frames
to the document, and then trigger them. Well,
that's a lot of work to do in JavaScript.
It means that you now have to go write all
this out and trigger animations through JavaScript.
It's kind of a pain. You don't really want
to end up doing this. Instead, it would be
better if CSS gave us a way in our key frames
to say wherever I started from and wherever
I'm going to, calculated by the engine, please
go run this animation in a relative way to
those start and end states. And so we can
combine that. And in this case we're going
to try from some position on the left, wherever
we started, to some position on the right.
But we're going to bounce. We can use the
key frame system that's available for CSS
animations today, but parameterize it with
where we start and where we end to tie the
animation syntax back into the transitions
so that we can visually communicate with the
sorts of things our application is trying
to do and configure it with this rich visual
language that we have and keep it through
animations.
Again, we're going to tie that back through
a transition so that when we move over, any
class that has the state-dash-left interaction
state associated with it, we can then apply
this animation. So it is a really great way
of starting to think about writing your CSS
as a series of nodes in a state graph. And
when we have a transition from one node to
the other, you can start to address the edge
of the state graph as opposed to start backing
this stuff back into your selectors where
you might otherwise have to try to target
something with a bunch of additional ID or
class rules in order to kick off some particular
transition or some particular animation.
We think this is really powerful stuff and
it is going to open up a whole bunch of new
complex behavior in animations and transitions.
But we're working in a bunch of other areas,
too. At the last hour, I gave a talk on JavaScript,
and at JSConf and Node Conf last week, we
unveiled JavaScript to JavaScript compiler
called Traceur. It is to help us innovate
in exactly the same way but for the JavaScript
language so that we can start to prototype
ideas out quickly, work with the standards
committees, work with the broader community
to help understand whether or not these ideas
are good ideas or bad ideas.
As Alex said, a lot of this stuff is prestandards.
We are working hard to make sure these are
the best designs we could come up with, but
we need your help to do it.
So we're working in CSS to go add a whole
slew of other stuff, too, because CSS is one
of the weaker parts of the Web platform today.
CSS rule values, CSS layouts, better performance,
a layout model that's easier to use and easier
to understand when you're positioning things
relative to each other and a real object model
for scripting all of this.
These are the sorts of things that we are
focused on. We don't have time to go through
all of them today, but I hope you'll engage
with us through the XS project, which is on
Google Code today, which gives us the ability
to prototype this in a preprocessor style,
the same way that Traceur does for JavaScript,
less sass, the sorts of preprocessors that
you might have come to use. But it operates
on the client side. And so it is a really
powerful facility for helping to prototype
these features, use them early and get started
with a bunch of the new capabilities that
we hope that you're excited about for the
Web platform, too.
So, as I mentioned, we're working in Traceur
to help improve JavaScript. And improving
JavaScript happens at a lot of levels. JavaScript
is a language, but doesn't necessarily just
have its own library. The DOM is important
part of the JavaScript ecosystem. And so we're
working with not just the ECMAscript standards
body, but also the webIDL standards body to
help make the things that you do in JavaScript
more natural. Working on a CSS logic model
to help make interacting with JavaScript and
CSS much more natural and more fluid. So,
as a JavaScript programmer, you don't have
to think of those things as being alien to
your environment. They act the way that everything
else in JavaScript should. Hopefully, through
the Traceur project, you can help inform us
about whether or not we're scratching your
itches, too.
So the last piece I want to sort of go through
today, one of the big pieces of infrastructure
that we've identified as a common thing for
web developers to do that doesn't have a lot
of platform support today is the idea of templating
or data binding. Those are both scary words.
I understand. There's a bazillion templating
languages in the world. Data binding is something
that isn't the sort of idea you want to foist
on to newbies. HTML is a great language because
it allows you to go from zero to amazing applications
in a relatively linear path. So we don't want
to put a lot of code in the way between how
you start writing your application and where
it eventually ends up at. We want to supply
a path. HTML and the web platform have done
a good job at providing exactly that. If you
can't get it through HTML, maybe try it in
CSS. If CSS doesn't do it, maybe try JavaScript.
So these things have sort of fit together,
composed together in a way that's allowed
us to evolve from just a document rendering
system to a place where we're building real
applications. And that's a property we want
to preserve. So we asked ourselves, when we
generate all this stuff on the client side,
what is it we're trying to do?
And the key insight that Rafael Einstein and
other folks have come up with is that data
binding and templating are exactly the same
problem. They're two sides of the same coin.
On the service side, you wind up writing a
templating engine that takes your data, mixes
it together with some templates and then spits
out a string. Why does it spit out a string?
Because it's on the surface side, and you
have to serialize it to send it to the client.
On the client side, you wind up taking that
generated thing, because it's pretty fast,
and you wind up trying to attach some out
of band model or view to it so when something
changes through JavaScript events, you can
go be informed of it and tell the server and
reserialize the changes that you'd like to
notify the server of.
What if, instead, on the client side, we were
able to take a lot of the templating and do
it right there?
And so this is some sample syntax that we're
working with now where we're introducing a
new template element into HTML. And that template
element is creating an inert chunk of DOM,
which, in this case, we're going to use directly
because we're going to iterate over some property.
But that inert chunk of DOM iterates over
some items. It has an ID. It is actually an
element. And it's going to go grab some properties
out of the current item it's iterating. In
this case, we've got another template we're
going to use this is going to iterate over
the children property of the current item.
But it's going to not define its own template.
It's going to refer to another one. In this
case we actually have recursive templates
here and very little code. This would have
been a lot in JavaScript to write and send
down the wire just to do the string replacement.
But later in script, we can take a regular
JSON object. This is a regular JSON object.
This is not an object in some special format.
It's just JSON. We're going to wrap in this
model.get. And this is an ECMAscript harmony
proxies. ECMAscript harmony is the next version
of JavaScript. We're excited about proxies
because they give us a way to take any JavaScript
object and look at all the operations that
you might do on it. So, when you change it
directly -- add some property, delete something,
add something to an array, change some value
-- we can get informed of that. We can listen
in on that directly, so that you don't have
to send your data down the wire in a special
format in order to have it wrapped up in something
that can then notify you back about changes
to it. We can wrap it directly. We also want
to add a new model property to all HTML elements.
In this case, the model property is something
that's inherited. So, if there isn't something
else in the document that's going to iterate
or use a template, we'll see the items that
were inherited from wherever this element
was used in the document, which means that
the items property here in my JSON is going
to be the thing that we iterate over. We're
going to go run through all the items. And,
if they've got children, we're going to apply
this template once again while pulling the
name property right back out of it. This is
pretty cool. This is in 20 or so lines. We've
got the real ability not just to go generate
UI on the client side, sending down significantly
more terse data, but also wiring up the behavior
of observing yet a change and modifying the
UI. Let's look at an example of how this might
work. We've built, again, a prototyping library
that helps you work with this stuff today.
And it works in Mozilla Firefox, because they've
got good proxy support. So I like Firefox.
What I've got here is an example of a recursive
template. This, again, is available as a Google
code project. Google.code.com/model-driven.
Model-driven views give us the ability to
look at the source code for this page. So
we have our template. And we've got our data.
And it's exactly what we saw before. And this
is all driven by this little library. I commented
a bunch of stuff out. But let's see what it
looks like live. So this page, you know, loaded
pretty fast, because it doesn't have to send
down an exploded version of the HTML. But
that model is also live. That model is something
I can change. So let's go and do that. I'm
going to come back in here and grab a snippet
of code, which, if we can read this, this
code just takes the model. It's got some items.
We're going to read it back out. And we're
going to add a new JavaScript object to the
front of it. We're just going to add a single
object with a name property called Antarctica
to the front of our items. We're just going
to mutate in line through Firebug. Great.
Let's go paste that in. And what we see here
is that the document got updated in realtime.
We didn't have to do anything special. We
didn't have to say, please, go rerender your
view. Please go change everything about your
document. In fact, it's only going to try
to mutate as much of the document as the underlying
data that changed. The model-driven views
concept is incredibly powerful because, if
you're going to script this stuff or put an
event handler on it or put references to generated
content, it isn't going to blow up underneath
you unless your data changes. This is an incredibly
powerful thing. You're not going to be hands-off
on DOM that's generated from these templates.
We think this is a really critical procedure
both from performance because we're only calculating
and updating as much UI as has been calculated
from the data but also for scriptability.
We want to maintain the simplicity. If you
change your data, your view should update,
but only the parts that would have otherwise
been updated.
So model-driven views are the sort of thing
that are incredibly powerful. We hope that
other web engine vendors will help us out
and help us -- help inform us about what's
working well and what's not in this system,
as we go to take it through the standards
process and put it in implementations. But
the question for you is sort of between JavaScript,
between CSS, all the CSS improvements and
the model-driven view stuff, when can you
start to use it?
It's an important question. And we've been
using a series of prototypes to help us start
to write real code in these systems. Our view
has been that, if you propose a new spec and
you don't have an implementation, you don't
have a way to run real code through it, you're
going to sort of miss stuff. We have a long
history of sort missing stuff on the web platform.
So, if we can use prototypes to write a lot
of real code in these styles today, we can
catch a lot of the stuff early. And, in fact,
we've been working with some of the authors
of some the existing systems, like less, to
help inform our view of what the platform
can do and where the gnarly corner bits are
that we're going to have to watch out for
early. So we hope you'll join us at these
open source projects. Start using this stuff.
Start using these prototypes, and start working
with it in your own code insofar as you can
to give us feedback. Help us understand whether
or not these new features are right for your
application, whether or not they're solving
the pain points that you're seeing in your
apps. Because we took a survey of our apps.
But we, certainly, aren't the entire world.
And we're curious to know if this is the sort
of stuff that's going to really be off for
you.
The next step in the standardization process
is always to get browser vendors to implement
things. It's one thing to say we think this
is going to work in a JavaScript library and
we think this is grog to work in a prototype,
but we really need to know if it's going to
apply in an important way in implementations.
So Mozilla Firefox and Chrome are all starting
to work early in the standards, as we've done
in things like the Cloud system and video
tag to go add new features to the web platform
quickly so you can start to use them in places
like the web store or in extensions, things
that aren't subject to the churn and the regular
set of constraints of deploying an application
to the full web.
And things like Chrome Frame, the sorts of
protected environments that are adding new
features quickly and auto updating, are going
to help make the future of the web platform
a reality. But we need your help to do it.
We need you to work with us to try out these
features. Give us feedback. Help understand
-- help us understand where you're still spending
a lot of time writing stuff out for the savant
and not saying what you mean. Because we really
need to get to a place, we think, where, when
you write a web application and go and construct
something, you're thinking about what it is
you're going to get done and less time thinking
about what it is you needed to say to get
it done. So thanks so much. I think we'll
open it up for questions now.
[ Applause ]
>>Ian Fette: We've got mics in the middle
of the room. We'd be happy to take questions.
>>> Hello. Thank you for the talk. I was wondering
if you're familiar with the app engine channel
API. And, if so, how that technology relates
or compares to the WebSockets technology.
>>Ian Fette: So, if I recall the app engine
channel -- I think is that browser channel?
So browser channel, what it, essentially,
does is it opens two concurrent connections.
One is for downstream. One is for upstream.
And so, first of all, one difference right
there is you've got now two connections to
your back end instead of one. And, if you're
scaling up to a large number of users, the
number of connections can actually become
a limiting factor. So that's one difference.
Two, even though you've got that, you're still,
often times, having to close -- I forget if
it's the upstream or the downstream connection.
I want to say it's the downstream connection
you have to close each time you send something.
Otherwise there are intermediaries that will
cache whatever is being sent or buffer it.
So you create a new connection. You then have
all the cookies that get sent, all the headers.
So your data transfer gets blown up by a lot.
So WebSockets has one connection instead of
two. It's persistent. So you don't have all
the headers going each time. And WebSockets
also supports binary data. So, if you're sending
binary data, you don't have to UTF it. You
don't have to base 64 encode it. You don't
have to, like, shove it in some giant string
or giant JSON format. You can send it, however,
you want. WebSockets is designed to be a more
efficient implementation of bidirectional
communication. So same use cases but much
more efficient.
>>Alex Komoroske: I should say the channel
API today presents a simpler case to you,
the user of the API. But it is, ultimately,
doing the stuff under the covers, which has
all the extra headers, closed connections,
and all this extra stuff.
>>> Thank you.
>>> This is probably a little early to ask.
But I'm curious with the model-driven views,
if you go and inspect the DOM and try to edit
it later? Are you editing the template or
rendered result? Or do you get to choose which
side you're on?
>>Alex Russell: So when you go with model-driven
views, our goal is to extract out the latent
driven model that's in HTML. If you think
about structuring your HTML, you've got form
inputs. Hierarchy of your document, semi-semantic
tags. In that case, we just sort of want to
make it easier for you to transition to a
world where you're modifying your data and
not so much modifying the DOM. If you can
get away with modifying your data and propagating
sort of input events back to your data to
your model and have that regenerate the DOM
that you've got, that's the nirvana. That's
the place we all want to be, where we don't
have to think so hard about what's going to
happen when I modify this piece of DOM. If
you do have to modify DOM, the template isn't
unlike HTML 2 templates. You wind up in a
place where, if I change the template, which
you can do later, it will take effect the
next time I apply it, the next time I stamp
out new instance of that template. But existing
instances of the template aren't affected.
If I go and change the generated DOM, there's
the potential we may disconnect the two. We
don't want to really sort keep you from doing
that. But you may no longer see updates that
are generated back from the model.
>>> Thanks.
>> Ian Fette: In the back, I think.
>>> I have a question. I built a small HTML5
thing for myself that used the HTML5 audio
tag. And then I was dragging and dropping
files from the local computer to then populate
that audio tag.
And I ran into a couple problems with, actually,
dropping a blob onto the page and totally
crashing the page by dumping 5 megabytes of
memory onto it. But, as far as -- but I'm
wondering how the file system API and the
HTML5 audio tag or the HTML5 video tag could
interact with each other and, if that's being
thought of.
>>Ian Fette: So, without knowing the exact
details of your implementation, there are
certainly ways that you can, like, try to
get a data URI from whatever is dropped on.
And that turns into some giant amount of memory.
One of the cool things that comes from the
file system is a class called file reader.
So you can, essentially, rather than having
to get a -- just like the whole contents of
the file and put that in some data URI, you
can use file reader to seek around parts of
the file. You can get a URI that you can then
put inside the source attribute of an audio
or video tag. So what we're really trying
to do is we're trying to make sure that anything
you store in the HTML5 file system API or
anything that you get a reference to, like
if someone drags a file on or someone chooses
a file from an input type equals file dialogue,
we want you to be able to get sort of a handle
to that file and then do intelligent things
with the file wherever it already is without
having to copy it. So get a URI that you can
shove in an image tag, an audio tag, open
a file, reader or writer, that you can seek
or read or write parts of the file. Like,
we really want, like, all these things that
you can do on Unix when you just F open a
file, F seek, F read, F write. We want those
simple use cases in a way that's, obviously,
safe for the web but in a way that's equally
performant and expressive. That's really our
goal.
>>> That's great. Thank you very much.
>>> I would like to ask what is the plan for
the hardware or device supporting HTML5 starting
from, for example, most common devices like
web cam or the microphone or smart card readers.
>> Ian Fette: We have a team that's working
on microphone and camera input. It's not quite
there yet. But we do want to make it so that
you can do -- like we have a whole group inside
of our team that's focused on what we call
realtime communications. So how do I get access
to the microphone and video camera? That's
one part of it. But then, once I get access
to it, what do I actually do with it?
It's one thing to be able to put that into
a canvas or video tag and display it on the
screen. But then how do I take that data and
transmit it somewhere? Like, if I'm doing
streaming, I don't really want to use WebSockets.
Because that's TCP. And, if I'm on a slow
connection, I'd rather just drop frames than,
you know, make the other guy wait. So we're
-- we're not there yet. But we are doing a
lot of work around video and audio and streaming
that, in particular.
As for other types of devices, it's sort of
an open question. There's a few proposals
for how to deal with sort of letting the browser
interact with types of devices it doesn't
know about yet. So, like, a new input device,
a new game pad. It's still sort of in the
early days of specs. And there's not really
that much that you can play with at this point.
>>Alex Russell: My personal hope is we get
to a place where a lot of these things have
an easy onramp and a sophisticated API behind
them. So, if I have the device capability,
the input tag gives you access to that thing.
Files, for instance. that seems like a good
analogy where you could hang a sophisticated
DOM off it later. But still have an easy onramp
for web authors. There's a lot of permissioning
questions like how many info bars are we going
to throw? It's complicated but coming.
>>> Thanks.
>>> Hello, with the new templating scheme
that you showed us in all of your data living
in JSON somewhere, what would be the implications
for SEO?
>>Alex Russell: That's a great question. In
fact, my hope is that, because a lot of this
can be declared -- what we showed you is the
data in JSON, but the template in HTML. Those
things don't have to be that way. The data
could be HTML. If the data is HTML, then you've
got the content that you're trying to express
there. And, if that has the links in the content
that is important to the web engine, that
gives you degradability, for one. But it gives
you the ability to search. The other question
is how smart can the web crawlers be?
So a lot of that is declarative. We showed
you imperative version. But, if a lot is declarative,
then there's a hope we cannot have a big gap
in support as this rolls out.
>>Ian Fette: Hopefully, it makes it easier,
if you look at what the -- obviously, there's
school.com. But there's also insider Google.
there's things like product search and trying
to extract meaningful, actual, like, data,
not just strings of text, entities, entity
recognition. So this will, hopefully, make
that easier. But we are still in the early
days.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Alex, data banding to model, framework
to date? It's built into the platform. You
don't have to send it down the wire.
>>Alex Russell: A lot of these things, I should
say, are predicated on not inventing something
brand-new but looking at existing best practice
and trying to work backwards and say what
could we do in the platform, if we had the
power to change the platform? A lot of the
toolkits like I worked on before I joined
Google can do a lot of the same things, but
they can't do it in as natural a way. So the
opportunity for the platform is to do it -- express
the capacity in the most natural way for you
as a developer and so not to go necessarily
plow new ground entirely but to go figure
out what's working and then just make it faster,
easier, and simpler for developers.
>>> Okay. Thank you.
>>> Hey. I noticed in the template, that was,
basically, a four loop. Oftentimes in template
like in Jango, we have like "if", which is
useful but I know also some people are uncomfortable
with things like "if" in templates.
How far are you guys going to go in terms
of that stuff and logic?
>>Alex Russell: So there is a small expression
language, basically which ties back to JavaScript.
But that's, again, not going to be language
dependent and won't tie necessarily to JavaScript,
whatever is there.
But the hope is you won't have to rely on
that. If a property isn't available, there's
going to be a pipe filter syntax like you
might see out of -- there is a pipe filter
syntax in the MBV prototype today, the sort
of thing you might see in Jango where you
can run filters through.
One of the things you could do is specify
the hidden property from HTML5. If you want
something to not be output, you can just hide
it and that gives you the ability to do a
lot of conditional logic based on the structure
of your data without necessarily going to
programmatic expression which, again, is going
to be the sort of thing that defeats SEO or
machine recognition of what you have done.
>>> Thanks.
>>> What's the status of IndexedDB? And how
long do you think it is going to be practical
before we can actually make end users have
good use of it?
>>Ian Fette: Yeah, so, right now we've got
support for all of the asynchronous IndexedDB
-- we have support for all asynchronous IndexedDB
on Chrome dev.
We are doing a few things right now to make
it more performance. So our initial implementation
was using SQLite as a backend, and we found
this to be sort of unacceptably slow for a
lot of transactions. So we have a new backend
called LevelDB.
We are working on trying to get that in Chrome
13 as well as working on a synchronous set
of APIs for IndexedDB that are available for
workers.
Hopefully in, like -- by the end of the month,
it should be pretty usable with the new backend.
There's a chance that might slip into early
June.
But definitely very soon, we will have the
new backend and all the IndexedDB, asynchronous
and Worker Synchronous APIs working in Chrome.
So broadly summertime.
>>> All right, thanks.
>>> Hi. Are you working on standardization
of background pages or background apps?
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Fette: As we both look at each other.
So, you know, we had this interesting discussion
over beer a night or two ago about background
pages versus workers.
And workers are absolutely awesome because
there is a lot of things that you want to
do off the main threads, some heavy computation,
but then there is also things you want to
do off the main thread that requires some
access to the DOM.
So the prototypical example of this is image
manipulation. Sure you can try to code everything
up in JavaScript. It would be really nice
just to have a canvas in -- off the main thread
that you can do manipulations with, but you
can't have a canvas without the DOMs. So we
get into this whole thing of background pages.
And, yeah, I mean, there's a lot of great
use cases for it. There's also things like,
I've got an offline email app and it wants
to check for email every half-hour and how
am I supposed to do that?
It's something we're trying to figure out.
We don't have a clear path right now, but
there's so many use cases for it, we have
to figure out a way. It is just a matter of
when and how.
>>Alex Russell: This is the return of viewable
shared state, right? That's the thing we never
want to get into as a platform. We never want
to have some other thing running in parallel
to your application which can go unexpectedly
change that stuff out from under you causing
you to have to create some new text primitive
or something like that.
But at the same time, we need sort of zero
copy or one-copy access to a lot of those
things so we can shuttle them back and forth
across these processes.
It is not clear exactly how this is going
to be won, right? Maybe there's some model
like transactional shared memory, something
like that.
But for now, we're doing this sort of one-off
when you have a big use case, like image processing.
Let's make Canvas data available. So those
are the sorts of things where if we can see
where computation is going to be needed and
we can off load it, maybe we can build a bridge
from the DOM to that computational unit.
>>> The reason I'm asking is one of the last
things missing to have an alternative to native
Android apps to HTML5 because you don't have
the background wake up the app or something
with HTML5 apps.
>>Ian Fette: I think it is a part of a much
broader question which is sort of how do we
get away from the model where the application
always has to be running? Like, on Android,
I don't have the entire mail application running
all the time. And, yet, my email is still
syncing.
How do we get Web applications to a point
where they can be told by a server that something
interesting has happened and they should process
it without having to run the full application?
I think that's sort of a broader question
that we definitely need to solve, especially
as we try to target mobile devices like phones
and Chromebooks and -- I mean, it is something
we have to solve.
>>Alex Russell: The question is which part
of the Web platform is going to reach down
and intercede on your behalf with the OS.
Open question.
>>Ian Fette: All right. Thank you all so much
for coming. We really appreciate it. I hope
you have a great rest of the day here at Google
I/O. Thanks again.
[ Applause ]